police here in the german capital berlin
have come up against anti-lockdown
protesters
hundreds of people took part in marches
in the city despite a court order
banning such gatherings police in riot
gear used pepper spray and physical
force in an attempt to break up the
demonstrations
they've also detained a number of people
the protests against coronavirus
lockdowns in germany have attracted a
mix of groups
including anti-vaccination activists
conspiracy theorists
and the far right
[Music]
dw's thomas sparrow is at the
brandenburg gate
in the heart of berlin where the
original protest
was due to end thomas what's the
situation there on the ground
well the situation here is very diverse
it has been
tense throughout the day but unlike
previous
protests of this type there hasn't been
one
centralized protest here we've been
across
different districts of berlin and you
have seen pockets of
protests there that the police have
tried to disband but in general there
hasn't been that one very big protest
that maybe
the organizers had expected right here
at the heart of berlin i spoke earlier
with police spokespeople who said that
over 2
000 police officers were on duty and
that their main
matter of concern their main goal today
was precisely to try and disband
those protests or the groups of people
who were actually coming here
despite the fact that these protests had
been banned in advance
out of concern for a possible increase
in the number of coronavirus infections
also because police consider
that many of the people who normally
take part in these
protests do not respect some of those
coronavirus restrictions like
wearing masks or observing social
distance
and what exactly are these people
unhappy about
this is a very very diverse group of
people one of their main issues is
actually
anti-coronavirus lockdown but as you
mentioned all
yourself in your introduction there's
also anti-vaxxers here there are people
who also for example dislike science or
normal medicine what unites them all and
that is something that has been said on
various
studies and reports on this is the fact
that they are anti-establishment they
are anti for example traditional
parties anti science anti traditional
media and that is something that has
united all these people here i've been
to various of these
approaches in the past few months and
you can clearly see that it's a very
diverse
group of people with very diverse goals
but in general they're against the
system
as we know it here in germany uh but the
lockdowns and restrictions are being
eased so is this having any effect on
this
on this movement you could
argue certainly that this movement is
losing steam
as lockdowns are eased as a corona
situation has improved in the last few
months
but as i stressed earlier one of the
main components
here is that it's not entirely based on
the coronavirus pandemic it is one of
the main important
uh points but it is not the only one so
there are other
views other analyses that point to the
fact that this is a group that could
develop even after the coronavirus
pandemic ends
dw's thomas sparrow reporting from the
heart of berlin thank you